[Music]
Justin Bieber Daniel Caesar and gibeon
bring peaches to the 2022 Grammy Awards
I'm excited this is our first time ever
performing it together
jicks off the performance of their
nominated song sing
it down version at the piano
your skin
I wanna wrap my arms around you baby
never let you go but then they switch
things up and go more upbeat as Daniel
Caesar joins in Christ alone
[Music]
yeah Justin's wife Haley proudly sings
along to her hubby's hit in the audience
but she wasn't the only one grooving in
the crowd next up gibeon who takes the
stage with his signature Soulful voice
ahead of the ceremony the singer chatted
with E.T about his vocal ability and the
moment he realized his special gift once
I get into High School my voice kind of
like dropped so I thought it was weird I
thought it was too deep and then I
discovered Frank Sinatra because of the
Grammys actually they did they do like a
program in La for just like inner city
Youth and they they had me a part of
that program and they teach you music
education and they told me to go look up
the song called Fly Me to the Moon I
never heard of it I just went on YouTube
and looked it up and it was a guy named
Frank Sinatra singing in like a lower
register and I was like oh wow
peaches was nominated for four Awards
and even though it didn't win any
performing was a big feat for gibeon who
used to work in a restaurant I was a
server for five years and bubblegum they
have this
soup that's made out of shrimp that you
have to get into and pull people in and
I have to be in a suit also like so we
play it's based off Forrest Gump and so
pretty much I seen Tom Hanks every day
so where's the camera one of these if I
see Tom Hanks I'm sorry we got a fight
or something like I can't see that man
again I really can't and there's no
looking back Justin Daniel and gibeon no
doubt left a mark on the Grammy stage
[Music]